okay guys i see everybody's been talking
about this shoe and i just want to come
forward and say
little nas x is clapping back big time
you know i'm keeping the energy positive
the 21 year old performer took to social
media over the weekend
to address the chatter over his new
music video for montero
call me by your name and the controversy
over his new
satan shoe collaboration
the video which was co-directed by lil
nas x
is filled with biblical and ancient
greek references
and at one point the 21 year old slides
down a pole to hell
to seduce the devil and give satan
a lap dance
[Music]
while some fans were loving it others
slammed it as immoral
and inappropriate for kids that's when
the musician
fought back pointing out that his music
is never intended for children
tweeting quote i am an adult i am not
going to spend my entire career trying
to cater to your children
that is your job little nas x responded
to several fan reactions on tick tock
too
this new call me by your name song by
lil nazex
unacceptable as a mother i need to speak
out against this because children are
impressionable
this song is going to make him start
pole dancing at the park and
children don't have ones to throw at him
he also sarcastically tweeted quote
showed my three-month-old niece the call
me by your name video
and she said uncle that was quite the
stupendous visual
why in heavens would any individual be
enraged over such a sensational
showpiece
i'm gonna go cry y'all
whose real name is montero lamar hill
says he expected the backlash
he opened up about the meaning of his
latest song
tweeting a letter he wrote to his 14
year old self about coming out as
gay writing that he knows people will be
quote
angry quote i know we promise to never
come out publicly
i know we promise to never be that type
of gay person
i know we promise to die with a secret
but this will open doors for many other
queer people to simply exist
in the opening for the music video he
also shares that he's done hiding his
true
authentic self in life
we hide the parts of ourselves we don't
want the world to see
we lock them away we tell them no
we banished them but here
we don't welcome to montero
this has been so much growth like beyond
just you know the fame and fortune like
mentally
spiritually i've grown so much but that
music video
isn't the only thing that has people
talking okay guys
i see everybody's been talking about
this shoe and i just want to come
forward and say
okay
on sunday lil na's x issued a faux
apology after he received a ton of
backlash over his collab with
brooklyn-based
streetwear company mischief 666 pairs of
shoes
each on sale for 1018 featuring a
pentagram pendant
and a reference to luke 10 18 a bible
verse about satan's fall from heaven
oh then there's this the shoes each
contain a drop of human blood
drawn from members of the mischief team
mixed in with
ink that fills an air bubble in the
sneaker
okay guys i see everybody's been talking
about this shoe and i just want to come
forward and say
okay
when republican governor christie gnome
of south dakota slammed
the shoes on twitter lilna's ex
responded quote
you're a whole governor and you on here
tweeting about some damn shoes
do your job and he doubled down in his
own defense writing y'all gotta admit
the shoe's hard
you cannot sit here and lie